bonjour françois balthus languedoc
bonjour monsieur car oui vous êtes le
directeur du comité martiniquais du
tourisme avec vous on va commencer par
faire un état des lieux global du
secteur
l'un des plus impactés malheureusement
un par cette crise sanitaire la crise de
lakovic 19 au duc ovide 19 ont dit les
deux maintenant
alors après ces six mois françois
balthus languedoc est ce que finalement
le secteur a connu quand même un sursaut
même léger notamment avec la période des
grandes vacances là qui vient de
s'achever
où la situation at elle continué de se
dégrader ou d'empirer alors
effectivement il ya eu il ya deux phases
il ya eu la phase de confinement à et
après des débuts de déconfinement entre
mars et juin qui a été catastrophique
évidemment les commerces les secteurs de
touristiques étaient fermés pas de
revenus on a une enquête nous dit que
environ on avait une moyenne de 55 jours
de fermeture pour les entreprises du
tourisme pour les pour les hôtels on
était à 68 jours donc voilà et c'est
vrai que au mois de juin
il ya eu beaucoup de flou aussi au
niveau des protocoles
on a loupé une fenêtre de tir pour les
réservations qui était début juin mais
les comme les protocoles et est très
restrictif où était encore un peu flou
donc ça a pu poser quelques problèmes
pour les réservations
donc deux des grandes vacances et puis
après il ya la deuxième phase est une
phase beaucoup plus positive puisque à
partir du moment où nous avons eu donc
le test qui a été rendue obligatoire et
vous souvenez que le cnt s'est vraiment
battu pour que ce test soit rendue
obligatoire pour protéger la population
et favoriser un re démarrage de du
secteur et là nous avons quand même de
bonnes nouvelles nous avons de bonnes
tendances se sont dégagées août à bas
coût de juin juillet août
c'était une bouffée d'oxygène pour noces
au professionnel parce que les
martiniquais ont répondu présent nous
avons donc lancé deux campagnes si vous
vous souvenez on a lancé la campagne
partir en vacances en martinique est
parti en musique en martinique
et la combinaison des deux a a eu un
résultat absolument fabuleux alors j'ai
pas aujourd'hui une enquête précise mais
j'ai évidemment une belle tendance des
hôteliers qui ont rempli leurs hôtels
les restaurants ont là aussi douce mais
si vous voulez je vais vous donner
quelques exemples moi j'ai des petites
structures hôtelières qui ont fait 100 %
en juillet et août
non mais c'était inimaginable quand on
se quand on refile mais enfin fin juin
on s'attendait pas à ça j'ai des plus
gros porteurs dans le sud de la
martinique qui ont fait moins 8 par
rapport à l'année dernière
c'est fabuleux -10% par rapport à
l'année dernière
donc vraiment c'était 7,7 ces grandes
vacances les martiniquais et les voix de
louper un joué le jeu ils sont venus ils
ont est pas seulement pour les hôtels
mais aussi pour les activités de loisirs
les gîtes les maisons d'hôtes ont très
bien fonctionné
il ya peut-être les hôtels d'affaires
qui ont moins bien fonctionné puisque
évidemment c'est les grandes vacances et
est traditionnellement c'est plus
compliqué oui alors cela dit la
situation n'a pas tellement tellement
changé non plus du point de vue des
conditions alors peut-être quelques
personnes sont un peu plus enclines à
voyager maintenant qu'on commence à
s'habituer à vivre avec le virus mais
enfin c'est quand même toujours un peu
dissuasives toutes les conditions qu'il
y a alors on rappelle que le test de
détection et à leur on parle et de son
sourire toujours arriver en mer a
fortiori en martinique en revanche est
ce qu'on est toujours dans une fin de
période de quatorze haine de certaines
pauses et à l'arrivée tout ça ça lui a
disparu depuis ne change pas entendu
alors la haute saison approche à elle
doit commencer en général vers la fin
octobre dès novembre c'est à peu près ça
alors justement comment vous envisagez
cette haute saison qui sera particulière
parce qu'on a compris qu'on en a
peut-être pour quelques semaines encore
voir quelques mois et en particulier
pour la croisière est ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'il faut faire une croix
pour ainsi dire sur la saison de la
croisière 2020 2021 alors
effectivement nous la relance parce que
c'est un petit peu de ça qu'on va parler
nous l'avons imaginée en cas de face
donc là nous avons eu la phase locale et
régionale
pendant les grandes vacances
effectivement maintenant la haute saison
nous entamons cette phase de
commercialisation et de promotion sur le
national et l'international
alors donc évidemment là en septembre
octobre c'est un ces deux mois qui vont
être pas très bon mais ça septembre
c'est le sait le mois le plus mauvais de
l'année normalement entre guillemets
dans des conditions orco vide alors là
effectivement la haute saison
il ya la croisière alors la croisière
c'est un c'est un sujet qui évidemment
est important alors il ya quand même de
bonnes nouvelles c'est que ms et vous
savez que nous sommes tête de ligne en
martinique 1 pour mfc a commencé a donc
ses opérations en méditerranée
mi août donc ça c'est c'est vraiment une
belle initiative et en plus ils n'ont
pas de soucis alors ils ont des
protocoles extrêmement strictes et ils
n'ont eu aucun souci sur leur navire
donc pour l'instant ils font du de
l'italie grèce voilà il ya aussi costa
alors donc aimer c'est a commencé le 16
août
costa vienne commencé là le week-end
dernier je peux enfin début septembre il
y avait aussi le ponant qui a commencé
sur l'islande
alors maintenant sur les caraïbes oui
alors les caraïbes
il y a aujourd'hui la cdc qui est
l'équivalent de la rs a émis 1 ce qu'ils
appellent un ordre de
une interdiction de la croisière
carrément jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
activité alors aujourd'hui on travaille
beaucoup à la martinique aussi la
guadeloupe a et puis les autres il en
travail sur des nouveaux protocoles donc
donc là on verra donc voilà donc pour le
moment il ya un an sur un 2 sur 10
devraient juste précisé que pour
l'instant on a toutes nos escales la
majorité des escales ont été maintenus
et en principe on commence la saison le
27 octobre avec msc en principe d'accord
alors la saison d'aider des voyageurs
des croisiéristes qui arrivent mais bon
les martiniquaises et les martiniquais
vous pensez qu'ils ont l'esprit eux à
partir en croisière
oui c'est une vraie question mais c'est
une vraie question
on a fait un sondage qui
qui dit qu'en seulement 4000 à peu près
4000 martiniquais seraient prêts à
partir en croisière dans les 12
prochains mois
donc c'est sûr que voilà sa réponse à
votre question et surtout que ces
protocoles qui sont mis en place
alors évidemment ils sont extrêmement
strictes pour protéger les passagers et
les populations des escales dont alors
c'est nécessité cinq lettres ont peu de
tissu et souhaite un peu dissuasif
puisque ça va un peu à l'encontre de la
convivialité de la croisière
mais bon c'est donc on attend un peu
pour voir ce sera bien sûr c'est bien
sûr en phase iii du déconfinement la
martinique était classée en vert
entre temps il ya eu un classement en
rouge
oui alors bon ça aussi c'est peut-être
un peu dissuasif
et puis sur votre site vous n'oubliez
pas aussi de faire passer un message de
l'information certes sur l'épidémie de
covin mais également sur la dengue
mairie oui mais comment bien se protéger
des moustiques etc
bon enfin voilà tout à faut pas oublier
ça il y a également cet aspect qui dont
il faut au moins qu'il faut évoquer
françois balthus languedoc directeur du
cnt comité martiniquais du tourisme
comment réinventer certains domaines de
cette industrie touristique chez nous on
l'a vu les conditions de voyage de
séjour sont sujettes à caution à
quelques restrictions
or on voit des îles à côté qui vante le
télétravail au soleil au bord de la
caraïbe et ses bons d'autres peuvent
vendre leurs îles nature comme tout à
côté à la dominique enfin chacun a ses
atouts alors nous sur quoi on va
s'appuyer pour les autres je pense que
dans un premier temps puisque se
réinventer il faut il faut d'abord
s'adapter et c'est vrai que les
socioprofessionnels aujourd'hui se sont
adaptés à la coved 19 en étant en
innovant au niveau des entreprises
et puis donc nous notre territoire
dans un premier temps c'est un
territoire qui est rassurant puisque
nous avons vous fait 60 plus de 70 % des
visiteurs des touristes sont avant tout
des eaux des taux des touristes
nationaux
donc c'est vrai que venir en martinique
dans cette période troublée au niveau
sanitaire c'est plutôt rassurant donc il
fait d'avoir rassuré et puis après
effectivement on a plein d'atouts on
sait très bien que l'ama la martinique
est plurielle dans ses activités
donc ne nous nos priorités pour pour les
dires des atouts par rapport à au
contexte et à ce qui est un petit peu
dans les esprits ce que vous disiez qui
se veut alors à la fois rassurant des
gens qui se situerait d'évasion mais oui
la réassurance est ce qu'il ya de plus
important c'est cette le ça va être le
premier à tous vraiment après
effectivement il ya la nature le spiri
tourisme d'accord est donc d'accord
alors c'est du direct
on va on va terminer parce que j'ai on a
une alerte on a une bouche qui s'est
déclenché entre les chèques vacances ça
marche et ça n'a pas marché
rapidement il ya eu un petit peu de
retard mais ça va être mis en place dans
les prochaines semaines merci françois
balthus languedoc qu'on doit écourter
comme ça
[Musique]